So I stopped abruptly 12
minutes into the last video
because 12 minutes was too long.
I needed a break.
But where we left off, we
were in the home stretch.
We were evaluating the
third surface integral.
And we were setting it up as
a double integral with respect
to r and theta.
And we just had to
set up the bounds.
And we know that r takes
on values between 0 and 1.
And theta takes on values
between 0 and 2 pi.
So r, we're going to integrate
with respect to r first.
r takes on values
between 0 and 1.
And theta takes on values
between 0 and 2 pi.
And so now we are
ready to integrate.
So let's do the first part.
Let's do this inside
part right over here.
And I'm just going to
rewrite the outside part.
So this is going
to be equal to-- we
have our square root of 2
times the integral from 0
to 2 pi of-- and we have
d theta right over here.
So that's the outside.
This inside part
right over here,
we can rewrite it as
if we distribute the r.
It's r minus r squared
cosine of theta.
Now we're going to
integrate with respect to r.
So when we integrate with
respect to r, cosine of theta
is just a constant.
So if you integrate
this with respect to r,
you get-- and I'll do
it in that pink color--
if you integrate with respect
to r, the antiderivative of r
is r squared over 2.
And the antiderivative
of r squared
is r cubed over 3 minus r
cubed over 3 cosine theta.
This is just a constant.
And we're going to
evaluate that from 0 to 1.
So when you would
evaluate it at 1,
you get 1/2 minus
1/3 cosine theta.
So you get 1/2-- I'll just
do it right over here--
1/2 minus 1/3 cosine theta.
And then minus both of
these evaluated at 0,
well those are
just going to be 0.
0 squared minus 0
squared times whatever.
It's all going to be 0.
So this business
right over here just
evaluates to 1/2 minus
1/3 cosine of theta.
And so we get the integral.
This is all going
to be equal now
to the square root of 2 times
the integral from theta 0
to 2 pi of 1/2 minus 1/3
cosine of theta d theta.
And this is equal to
square root of 2 times
the antiderivative
of 1/2 is 1/2 theta.
And the antiderivative of
cosine theta is sine theta.
So minus 1/3 sine theta.
And we're evaluating
it from 0 to 2 pi.
When you evaluate
these at 2 pi, you
have-- let me just write it all
out-- this is the home stretch.
I don't want to make
a careless mistake.
We have square root of 2 times--
let's evaluate it at 2 pi--
1/2 times 2 pi is pi minus
1/3 times sine of 2 pi-- well
that's just going to be 0.
And when you evaluate it
at 0, 1/2 times 0 is 0.
Sine of 0 is 0.
So that all comes out to 0.
So all of this business
simplifies to pi.
And we are done.
We've evaluated surface three.
It is square root of 2, or
the third surface integral,
or the surface integral
over surface three.
It is square root of 2 pi.
And we are done.
So this part right over
here is square root 2,
or root 2, times pi.
So this entire surface
integral that we started
like 80 videos ago, evaluates
to-- the orange part
evaluates to 0.
The blue part, 3 pi over 2.
And then the magenta part
is square root of 2 pi.
So we're left with 3 pi over
2 plus the square root of 2
pi is the value of our
original surface integral.